[Musik]
heute gibt's rassistisch früher man dies
besser hallo herzlich willkommen zu sein
ließ welt hatte gibt es ein
französisches bisher das nennt sich
paris drehte sehr und es wurde erfunden
von einem moment louis d'or und der hat
gelebt in maisons laffitte ich kenne nur
mehr sortiment aber maisons laffitte und
zwar ist es aber ich konnte früher recht
gut französisch sprechen denn ich hatte
acht jahre französisch unterricht an der
schule fahren
den rest habe ich vergessen ich weiß nur
noch 8 uhr et am perron g
das auto ist ein papagei du bist schön
sehr entgegen
das ist doch die wichtigste information
über mich wissen müsst bedeutet ich bin
lacht mich also heute gibt es ein
französisches heer und zwar besteht es
aus so ist sind so kleine teilchen man
kann es aber auch als große torte machen
und zwar ist es aus brand gebäck also
brandtag brand masse wird gefüllt mit
einer pralinen creme also mit einer
haselnuss creme die mache ich auch
selber und das ganze wird glaube ich
schon ziemlich lecker ich muss sagen zu
geben in frankreich habe ich nicht
gegessen
aber ich kann mir vorstellen wie es
schmeckt und im prinzip sind auch alles
nur basic zutaten und auch basis rezepte
ich starte jetzt zuerst mit der panini
und zwar ist es so was ähnliches wie
nugat denn es besteht aus haselnüssen
und zucker und mandeln
das wird karamellisiert und dann damit
später eben die füllung gemacht ich
nehme dafür 200 km/h finnische 200 gramm
mandeln 280 gramm zucker und 60 gramm
wasser
ich könnte wenn ich mir im google
translator arbeit könnte ich das video
auf französisch machen aber da müsste
ich halt immer wieder absetzen damit ich
die wörter halt
im kopf hat naja ich werde zuerst einmal
die haselnuss und mandeln einfach schön
rösten
das heißt hier in der pfanne schwenken
bis sie lecker duften
das dauert auch einen kurzen moment ihr
könnt auch im backofen machen aber ich
spare mir jetzt einfach dass mein
backofen denn hier funktioniert doch ich
bin nochmals noch andere kriterien aber
nicht die richtigen töne treffen
mai mit der ist wirklich schwierig denn
so chance
aha das wirklich französisch gehabt wow
sagen ich hab es damals nur abgewählt
weil mein lehrer nicht mehr so toll war
ganz liebe grüße an meinen ehemaligen
französischlehrer dämme die französische
sprache leider versaut hat ja ich muss
echt sagen ich war also ich muss schon
sagen ich war schon sprachbegabt also
ich hab sprachen wirklich super schnell
gelernt auch englisch aber bei uns auf
dem gymnasium wasser und deswegen bin
ich auch übrigens lehrerin geworden
wir überbringen jetzt einfach mal die
zeit denn guck mal ich war ab der
fünften klasse auf dem gymnasium bis zu
und wir hatten englisch und französisch
und nie was ein sprachiger unterricht
das heißt deine lehrer kommen reinreden
deutsch mit dir bringen wir alles auf
deutsch bei oder muss er nach hause
gehen und die ganzen vokabellernen und
ich meine wie soll man lernen die
sprache zu sprechen wenn ich mal die
denkkraft französisch spricht und dann
immer diese stupide kabel auswendig
lernen und da hat mich das echt also so
elfte klasse wie es hat mehr ich will
französisch ab obwohl ich echt gut war
und da hat mir außerdem damals habe ich
glaube ich schon mal erzählt
ich hatte im vortrag über den eiffelturm
gehalten über zur eifel und dann es gift
gegenüber gustav vfl und dann hat er mir
eine frage gestellt was mit der
freiheitsstatue in new york zu tun hat
und hat nämlich gibt und ich wusste dass
gustave eiffel die stadt wo auch gemacht
hat und dann hat er gefragt was da heute
drin ist und ich wusste nicht dass es
ein museum ist und deswegen heute zwei
gekriegt da war es für den perfekten
vortrag nur wegen der frage
und der war schon gemein dass ich das
dann abgewählt habe ja und dann habe ich
selber lehramt studiert und englisch
studiert und hab dann am an der
hochschule und am seminar und da geht's
liebe grüße an meinen ehemaligen
dozenten raus an dem herr denkt hat
thomas denkt bei dem hatte ich nämlich
dann englisch und ich habe bis dahin
englisch gehabt wegen meiner
englischlehrerin damals und der herr
denkt er hat die englische sprache
wieder zurückgebracht hat mir den
einsprachigen unterricht beigebracht und
zwar einfach perfekt und ich hab's
gelebt und dann war der
englischunterricht so für mich als
lehrerin
in der schule der schönste unterricht
spielerisch und einsprache ich den
kindern englisch beibringen
so muss sein okay wir warten mit nikons
jetzt sind die haselnüsse und die
mandeln perfekt gerüstet und ich kann
jetzt ins wasser zugießen
den zucker dazugeben und das ganze jetzt
hier einfach schön aufkochen lassen
das erinnert jetzt so ein bisschen an
gebrannte mandeln falls ihr euch haben
ein video erinnert und die lasse ich
jetzt einfach so lange kochen bis das
wasser verdunstet ist und dann wird das
ganze erst mal trocken und muss dann
aber noch mal weiter karamellisiert
werden und dann ist ja so ein bisschen
mit der hitze spielen als am anfang
nämlich gern hoher hitze damit einfach
schnell geht sobald der zucker dann
trocken wirtschaftlich aber die hitze
runter damit einfach das karamell nicht
verbrennt und bitter wird und das wasser
habe ich jetzt hier mitarbeit damit sich
der zucker wirklich gleichmäßig über die
mandel und haselnüsse legt ansonsten
kann es nämlich passieren dass einfach
alles zu schnell karamellisiert und dann
wirklich verbrennt also ich zeige euch
recht die zwischenschritte jetzt schön
kochen lassen bis es trocken ist
[Musik]
jetzt liegt der zucker ganz trocken um
die nüsse und jetzt schalte ich den herd
ein bisschen runter und das ist wirklich
schön langsam karamellisieren das geht
jetzt auch ein paar minuten bis sich der
komplette zucker aufgelöst hat und alles
einfach schön glänzt und dabei immer
schön rühren
[Musik]
so sieht das ganze jetzt aus so schön
glänzen und jetzt am besten hier direkt
auf seine back folie streichen
ganz vorsichtig sein denn karamell ist
wirklich super heiß und jetzt lasse ich
es hier einfach abkühlen und kann es
dann gleich so bald abgekühlt ist durch
pürieren das mache ich aber gleich
nachdem ich die brandner hergestellt
habe wenn ihr jetzt töpfe und pfannen
habt und da wirklich was karamellisiert
habt bekommt ihr die am besten sauber
wenn ihr sie mit wasser auffüllen
aufkochen last und dann löst sich der
zucker oder das karamell einfach durchs
wasser auf und man muss gar nicht
stoppen also ich mache das hier kurz
sauber und riecht mir dann schon mal die
zutaten für die konnten machen
[Musik]
für die brandmeister nämlich 60 gramm
butter 250 gramm wasser eine prise salz
200 g mehl und vier bis fünf eier brand
teil gesagt gar nicht so schwer wie
viele immer denken
ich gebe jetzt nämlich die butter in den
topf das wasser kommt dazu und die
zutaten dürfen ganz kurz kochen also
wirklich schön aufkochen lassen
wichtig ist eigentlich nur der prozess
mit dem abbrennen also nicht anbrennen
sondern abbrennen
und wenn die masse dann kocht in einem
schwung das mehl mit dem salz dazugeben
damit ein richtig schöner teig klopps
entsteht
es zieht am anfang so ein bisschen
falsch aus finde ich wollte einfach sich
alles nicht so gut verbindet aber jetzt
schön das mehl unterrühren und jetzt ist
wirklich wichtig rühren und rühren bis
sich am topfboden in weißer belag bindet
das ist dieser abbrennen prozess und
dadurch verändert sich einfach das
gluten auch im mehl und ich habe später
eben den vorteil dass der brand steigen
im ofen aufgeht und das mehl von außen
einfach diese gase hält und dann alles
schön luftig wird obwohl ich kein
backpulver brauche also echt ein toller
tag ich habe mich immer wie kann man
sowas erfinden
das war damals keine ahnung wie kommt
man auf so eine idee
[Musik]
so sieht der teig jetzt aus also hier am
boden wirklich so dieser belag der aber
nicht verbrannt ist und die teig
konsistenz dies einfach wie wie knete
muss man sagen also ganz anders
das habe ich den herd ausgemacht und
kant hierüber und jetzt könnt ihr
entweder mit einer schüssel arbeiten und
jedes ei gleich einzelnen unterrühren
im bug löffel oder wenn ihr sagt eure
arme sind schon überstrapaziert hat die
sind einfach die küchenmaschine als es
geht beides oder auch ein handrührgerät
denn das unter rühren das ist das schon
recht anstrengend
ich will jetzt erstmal den teig hier ein
okay das heißt nicht so elegant und den
topf dem laster jetzt am besten abkühlen
und die schicht am boden die löst sich
dann ab und das schmeckt echt wie
sowieso ein dünnes müsst ihr nicht mal
wegschneiden schmeißen das könnte so
einfach so nach
ich hätte es noch schlimmer gemacht und
jetzt drücke ich den teig hier am rand
so ein bisschen flach damit er einfach
schneller abkühlt
[Musik]
es ist ruhig schon mal dass es noch ein
bisschen fühlen kann
und dann gibt er gleich einen nach dem
anderen nation
normalerweise kann man es wirklich eine
richtig coole hier aufschlagen und rein
flöckchen lassen aber ich habe da echt
sonne sonne probiere ich muss die eier
vorher in schälchen aufschlagen
zum einen um eierschalen zu vermeiden
und zum anderen kann es leicht passieren
dass man ein schlechtes dabei ist und
dann habt ihr euch den ganzen tag
versauen
bitte lasst es noch für das sind also
ganz ganz heiß ist
am anfang sieht es übrigens so aus als
würde sich das niemand mit dem verbinden
aber rührt einfach fleißig weiter
entwickelt eine schöne homogene masse so
sieht die brand masse wirklich perfekt
aus
man sieht schon ganz gut das sähe wenn
man sie so hoch zieht einfach so schöne
spitzen bilder chats und die glänzt auch
schön und einfach von der konsistenz sei
nicht so fest aber auch nicht flüssig
schon also da muss man schon wirklich
mit der menge gut haushalten
es kann auch sein dass immer nur ein
eigelb noch dazu gibt stadt ein ganzes
und dann können das einfach schon
ausprobieren und wie gesagt wenn sich
diese schönen spitzen ziehen dann ist
perfekt minimal könnt ihr sogar noch was
dazu ich glaube ich gibt tatsächlich
noch eingezogen
ich erspare mir jeden kommentar
ja dann glänzt auch noch mal ein
bisschen besser
[Musik]
jetzt ist sie perfekt schaut ihr seht
ihr schöner stiftung und schöner gelang
ich habe zehn spritzbeutel und nehmen
sie jetzt einfach zwei weil die
brandmeister einfach ziemlich fest ist
und hier vorne habe ich eine stelle mit
10 mm durchmesser um sich schlagend
einfüllen brand eick gehört so zu den
einzigen zeigen die kinder nicht so gern
maschen
innerhalb nach nichts schmeckt nur so
ein bisschen 20 als speziellen doppel
beutel denn die brandmeister ist
wirklich sehr schwer unser fest und es
kann passieren dass ein beutel aufreißt
deswegen lieber doppelt und ich habe ich
jetzt schon backpapier auf der rückseite
habe ich kreise aufgezeichnet mit
ungefähr acht zentimeter durchmesser
dafür habe ich einfach hier diesen
aussteller genommen den ich gleich
wieder sauber machen muss aber wichtig
auf die rückseite zu malen damit er die
farbe einfach nicht auf der vorderseite
habt jetzt in spritzbeutel aufrecht
halten hier oben die hand hin zu die
andere hand führt und einfach einen ring
spritzen und daran zeigt einfach noch
sehr gut aufgeht wirklich mit viel
abstand auch drauf spritzen
[Musik]
wenn am ende nur noch so ein bisschen
teig drin ist dann mache ich ganz gerne
so dass ich es flach hinlegen datei
karte darüber streichen
dann könnt ihr nämlich alle zeigt es
doch noch mal nach unten kratzen den
spritzbeutel nochmal strang ziehen und
dann einfach den rest worauf stützen
jetzt will ich hier noch 1 1
damit bestreichen ich hier die ringe und
dann streue ich noch mandelblättchen
drauf durch das ei bekommen sie einfach
beim packen eine schöne farbe und die
mandelblättchen die gehandelt dazu das
wird dann das ist dann so ein schön
knapp papa jetzt gerne einfach mit den
mandelblättchen bestreuen und im
vorgeheizten backofen backen und ich
werde die backzeit dann auch nutzen um
schon mal die creme herzustellen und
ganz wichtig bei brand gepäck ist bei
brand gebäck ist dass die backofentür
auf keinen fall geöffnet wird und die
müssen wirklich gut durch gebacken sein
bevor es raus nimmt ansonsten fallen sie
nämlich wieder zusammen das werden
[Musik]
sieg
dennis pannen brot die backzeit
überbrücke ich jetzt wie gesagt mit der
creme zum einen stelle ich jetzt die
pralinées her als initiiert die
abgekühlten karamellisierte nüsse und
setzte einfach in einem mixer
zerkleinern besitzen mixa wirklich auch
super wichtig denn so klein bekommt man
sie ansonsten einfach nicht mit einem
messer dafür fühle ich den müsse jetzt
einfach in den multi zerkleinerer ein
und pulverisieren sie und die masse
sieht so aus also anfangs decken und
wirklich gar nicht dass aus diesem fonds
pulver aus diesen gemahlenen nüssen
diese masse wird aber die es ist
geschmacklich der hammer genau davon
wirklich jetzt die 100 gramm ab denn die
brauche ich gleich für die creme und
jetzt stelle ich eine creme partie sehr
herr also eine konditor creme im prinzip
ist das wie eine art pudding buttercreme
nur ein bisschen andere verhältnisse
dafür nehme ich 500 gramm milch 60 gramm
zucker 4 eigelb 40 gramm stärke etwas
vanille extrakt 250 g weiche butter und
wie gesagt 100 gramm praliné gebe jetzt
die eigelbe hier in dem topf den zucker
dazu etwas vanille extrakt dazu die
stärke und erstmal ein bisschen milch
jetzt kurz klümpchen frei verrühren
wenn man direkt die ganz allmählich dazu
gehst dann ist es nämlich schwieriger
die stärke können frei zu verrühren und
jetzt einfach die restliche milch
dazugeben und stehen pudding einmal
aufkochen lassen und das mache ich dann
ganz gerne nicht bei höchster stufe denn
es kommt darauf an welchen topf ihr habt
also bei mir mit dem kupfer top ist
wirklich so da kann ich den auf höchster
stufe oder auf mittel hoher hitze
einfach erwärmen und der kupfer topf
erhitzt sich gleichmäßig das heißt der
boden und die seitenwände werden
gleichmäßig heißt wenn ihr aber dünner
eben stand gehabt und dann auf volle
pulle geht passiert folgendes der
topfboden wird zu heiß die wände sind
kalt und dann brennt euch die milch in
der pudding am boden an
und oben kochs nicht mal und deswegen
sage ich auch meist immer auf mittel
hoher hitze denn so rennt einfach nichts
an
[Musik]
der pudding ist jetzt fertig den fühle
ich jetzt direkt um in einen teller
damit einfach schneller abkühlt ihr
könnt ihr natürlich auch ein top
abkühlen lassen aber es dauert einfach
schneller also wirklich schön flach
verstreichen und dann direkt an der
oberfläche mit frischhaltefolie abdecken
und mit direkter der oberfläche meine
ich wirklich direkt also so damit sich
keine haut bildet und ich gibt es immer
ganz gern in die täler sind die leitung
zum einen die hitze perfekt ab und
dadurch kühlt einfach schneller ab und
jetzt muss ich eigentlich nur noch
warten bis der pudding abkühlt bis die
törtchen abkühlen und dann kann ich
gleich alles zusammen kann ich hier
schon weiter machen wenn ihr möchtet
könnt ihr den pudding hier nochmal durch
ein sieb streichen oder durch das
fleißige lieschen aber da ist bei mir
echt super klümpchen frei geworden
daher sprach ich mir das heute guckt das
sind kleine klümpchen drin und die will
ich nicht immer erklären dass ich den
stress durch während sich das gleich
mache kann ich aber auch schon mal die
weiche butter verrühren
die darf nämlich ganz cremig gerührt
werden so richtig weiß cremig
[Musik]
wenn die mutter dann ganz weich ist
könnt ihr den flach hörer oder flexible
eintauschen gegen den schneebesen aber
muss er wirklich schon schön weich sein
denn damit lässt sich das ganze
voluminös aufschlagen und dann gebe ich
einfach es läuft weise den pudding dazu
und dann noch die pralinées
[Musik]
ich habe ich jetzt also das gebäck und
das wird jetzt einmal waagerecht
aufgeschnitten
ganz vorsichtig und dann sieht man auch
schon wir luftig es also richtig richtig
lecker
hallo hausaufgaben erledigt perfekt was
hattest du heute auf ich muss nicht so
fleißig schon okay das habe ich schon
mal erledigt ich lasse auch die decke
immer direkt drauf damit sich die kreise
und kriegen einfach nicht vermischen
dann hat man wirklich immer den
passenden deckel dabei dann kann ich dir
diese kräftig noch übrig habe also die
pralinées siehst du wie ich das
aufgefangen habe
[Musik]
genau so genau das ist drin
mein gott seit ihr feinschmecker kinder
das also samira erfüllt mich schon ein
bisschen drüber füllt die pralinées in
einen spritzbeutel mit einer lochtiefe
und geht für die buttercreme in einen
spritzbeutel mit einer pistole die
krieges nur ein bisschen weich bei mir
weil bei uns so innentemperatur im raum
ungefähr 50 grad hat ich hatte sie jetzt
auch ganz kurz im kühlschrank aber die
wird gleich im kühlschrank fest und dann
dann passt das ganze fest erzählt das
display kannst du französisch doch du
kannst einen satz den kann glaube ich
jedoch das heißt ich kann nicht
französisch sprechen das heißt wenn du
in frankreich ist und jemand spricht
sich auf französische modell und dann
sagst du entweder kannst antworten bosch
oder du sagst schöne paar frau sei aber
bitter rät weiter
ok ich probier's mal kurz aus denn das
darf da unten nicht raus flutschen
aber ich zeige euch hier war kurz einmal
die lufthülle dass eine kleine loch
thüle mit 7 mm ok alles probiert es mal
ich hoffe wir kriegen ist und ich also
wenn sie bei euch auch so weich dass
einfach im kühlschrank lagern jetzt
erstmal eine kleine schicht da die
füllung in die mitte das ist sozusagen
der kern und jetzt kommt die schöne
spritztechnik ich probier setzt ebenso
kringeln und auf zu spritzen
dahin geht drauf und so machen wir das
jetzt
[Musik]
osama mann bist du zur perfekten
konditor assistentin herangewachsen
ich glaube bald kann ich dir die rezepte
raussuchen und dann machst du dir
einfach
[Musik]
also ich habe jetzt mit buttercreme
menge gerade mal sieben stück folgen
können also ein achtes krise noch hin
aber die buttercreme menge muss man auf
jeden fall verdoppeln ich schreibe ich
einfach in die app und in den block
doppelte menge würde mir bescheid wisst
denn sonst kann man die nicht so schön
üppig füllen und die stelle ich jetzt
kurz in den kühlschrank und da werden
sie fest für etwa ein bis zwei stunden
und kurz vor dem servieren bestreichen
dann noch mit sitzung stehen und wir
machen noch mal buttercreme
[Musik]
schlimmes gletscherschnee sarah polley
wo morgens etwas kitschig moratorium
hatten wäre okay herr murat symbole wo
bisher das kommt mir spanisch vor
das bedeutet möchtest du das dessert
probieren meine macht ruhig
ich mache alles sauber sondern auch der
perfekte ehemann
vielleicht steckt ja auch gleich ja und
wie terrassenfenster mehr stopps auf der
terrasse der einzige mensch der die
terrasse stürzen
[Musik]
daisy magnifica
ich würde auch er stehe zu seinem mtv
weggenommen
die morgengold jemanden der teig
ich kann gar nichts sonntag
ich bin zur sprache nutzen ihr könnt die
übrigens auch wunderbar vorbereiten denn
die das brandgebiet kann man super
vorbereiten und auch ungefüllt also in
dem zustand auch einfrieren dann habt
ihr immer wasservorrat auch da und dann
könnt ihr einfach europa rebreak dessert
zubereiten
ich muss sagen ein ganzes schaffe ich
vielleicht nicht so viel also ein stück
reicht ja ich muss auch sagen folgen war
meine mutter echt sehr weich und ich
konnte gar nicht so richtig maximal
schaumig aufschlagen
wenn sie nicht ganz so weit es geht es
ein bisschen besser man hat mehr volumen
und dadurch dann eben auch weniger masse
in so einem ring aber schon so echt gut
es ist richtig schön also ein befehl war
ja so ist es jetzt ein schönes hochzeit
der sonst noch zählt zu unseren da war
nicht goldwind letzten schließen und so
weiß also benutzt hatte unten ja also
probiert dass das sehr gerne mal auf und
stellt eure kommentare und wenn ihr euch
weitere des erwünscht oder anregungen
oder ideen oder irgendwas habt schreibt
es mir einfach in kommentaren
also das rezept gibt es zum nachlesen
auf cds - pt und hoffentlich alle
abonnieren runterladen
mai nicht durch
komm ich
[Musik]